so war sie machen ein produkt teurer und
dann ist es besser oder wie es jedoch
trotz aus erstmal muss sind sozusagen
als preis wenn es preisgünstig oder
billig ist weil nicht die ursache dass
das krone ausgebrochen ist in den
schlachthöfen sondern die ursache waren
natürlich die schlechten hygiene
voraussetzungen in den
sammelunterkünften und natürlich dass
die menschen wahrscheinlich im betrieb
so nah aneinander gekommen sind
ja also die arbeitsschutz bedingungen
haben nicht gestimmt und jetzt dann zu
sagen jetzt der staat soll diesmal
richten
das fleisch ist einfach zu billig dass
wir einfach eine normale planwirtschaft
es ist ein bisschen schaulaufen wieder
hat er sie kennt mehr wege haben doch
und 22 euro 50 damals geheißen oder
benziner kommt alles irgendwie mal
wieder zurück von den grünen ja ja es
ist eine ideologisch moralische frage
die jetzt endlich mal politisch werden
muss und ich finde dass das ein sehr
gutes zeichen ist dass die
bundestagsbeschlüsse sich damit
auseinandersetzen die ja sagen dass die
arbeitnehmer gestärkt werden sollen dass
die werkverträge aufgelöst werden sollen
und die tatsache dass die csu jetzt auf
grünen linie ist das zumindest
dahingehend hoffen dass wir das thema so
gestalten dass sozusagen auch die
bedingungen unter denen diese
dumpingpreise zustande kommen nämlich
dumpinglöhne wo ein wirklicher
billiglohnsektor entstanden ist im live
betrieb in deutschland dass es
beschämend die arbeitsbedingungen sind
menschlichen sie sind beschämt und
deswegen ist das auch kein zufall dass
dort eben auch das korps ohne risiko
erhöht ist ich habe selber als
reporterin beispielsweise mal in
pasewalk einem fleisch betrieb
reingeschnuppert und danach hat sich
mein verhältnis auch komplett verändert
zu fleisch ich finde nicht dass das
leicht zu billig ist ja ein verwandter
ist sondern dass es zu billig ist und
dass wir wenn wir sozusagen dieses
fleisch essen auch zu den bedingungen
mit beitragen wenn die frage ist ja
immer was kann ich selber leisten ich
kann mich den ganzen tag darüber
beschweren dass die verhältnisse
sozusagen nicht gerechtfertigt so der
ist ja nicht böse wenn du jetzt das
fleisch teurer wachsen ja erstens mal
wird das tier wohl nicht besser dadurch
dann wird das geht bestimmt nicht bei
den bauern ankommen wo es ankommen
sollte dass sie besser tierschutz
bedingungen auch haben sondern es wird
ein händler bleiben oder in diesem groß
schlachtbetrieben bleiben und muss auch
damit rechnen dass dann heißt es wieder
okay
viele familien können sich das dann auch
nicht mehr leisten aber es gibt personen
ein ich habe drei kinder und wir sind
all die aspekte die wir gerade
angesprochen haben wichtig ich möchte
dass es unseren bauern gut geht ich
möchte qualitativ hochwertiges fleisch
ich kann es mir aber nicht leisten jeden
tag alles bio zu kaufen es geht für eine
55 köpfigen haushalt einfach nicht und
es ist auch irgendwie empfinde ich nicht
als gerecht wenn eben solche probleme in
unserem land dann auf den verbraucher
abgewälzt werden nicht nur auf den
verbraucher letztlich auch auf den
arbeitnehmer aber die gretchen frage die
wir uns stellen müssen ist ja wie wir
leben wollen und wie wir uns ernähren
wollen und die tatsache dass die
produktion von fleisch eben natürlich
auch seinen preis hat würden
zwangsläufig dazu führen dass es auch
teurer ist und ich glaube es geht
grundsätzlich darum inwieweit ich auch
bereit bin diesen fleischkonsum
zuzulassen
auch aus gesundheits erwägungen und ich
bin jemand der weit weg ist von
veganismus vegetarismus oder das
ideologisch besetzt aber ich glaube
schon dass ich in den letzten jahren
diesbezüglich dahingehend eine menge
verändert hat und dass es darum gehen
muss dann vielleicht auch zu gucken muss
es denn jeden tag sozusagen fällt
deswegen sein denn ich kenne es dass
auch viele deutsche gar nicht mehr
bereit sind in diesem fleisch betrieben
zu arbeiten deswegen muss man ja die
ausländischen kräfte dazu holen und die
frage ist warum sind aber da muss man
schlagen erdbeeren kirschen alle sehr
gut den tagebauen hat nämlich
festgestellt auch hier war bei den
sammelunterkünften ist corona
aufgetreten und das muss man natürlich
schauen geregelt man das in zukunft
werkverträge diesen würde ich jetzt
nicht das so ganz ganz schlecht reden
die haben auch manchmal ihren zehn
werktage bist du musst natürlich gewisse
überprüfung machen bei diesen
sammelunterkünften wir sind jetzt so
unternehmen die hauptsächlich arbeiten
du musst einigen vielleicht ein tüv-
oder sowas dass du sagst okay das musst
du musst du vorher checken oder du
machst eine zeiterfassung die kontrollen
müssen strenger wäre ein sieg und jetzt
auch nicht so mensch der in
nachkontrollen ruft ja wir deutschen
haben immer so das gefühl wenn wenn
kinder im sandkasten in die glasscheibe
steigt dann machen wir gleich eine
arbeitsgruppe mal nach der obrigkeit
hier muss was geregelt werden und keiner
passt mir selber auf
ja aber bei den sammelunterkünften finde
ich jetzt persönlich schon der meinung
dass da schon ein bischen überprüft
werden
also mehr als eine scherbe im sandkasten
zu sagen dass es gerade schon gesagt
patricia das ist natürlich auch für den
endverbraucher ein großes thema es ist
ganz klar
wissenschaftlich ausgestellt das
natürlich fleisch zu unserer ernährung
pyramide gehört der körper braucht die
proteine so das ist schonmal abgedeckt
die frage ist aber meiner meinung nach
wie oft braucht man das sollte man
vielleicht in der erziehung der
ernährung der menschen der
endverbraucher ein bisschen mehr
investieren und bist du mir aufklären
vielleicht 60 kilo fleisch im jahr ich
meine 59 60 kilo ist ja also das ist
eine menge
und wenn man so viel ist greift man
natürlich automatisch zu diesen in
orangensauce abgepackten 199 sonderpreis
dingen die man dann nachher auf dem
grill wirft und natürlich muss irgendwie
ein umdenken stattfinden dass wir dort
keine qualität die pausen und lebenslauf
ihn als unseren körper wo ich glaube das
umdenken findet schon statt wie zb ich
kenne bei mir zum beispiel ein metzger
da gibt es das billigere gleich aber es
gibt auch in theke daneben das teurere
fleisch und über der theke ist total
interessant läuft ein film moment zieht
wie das wie die fleischproduktion durch
sowie das tier 0 ist wie dass ein bauer
das ist bau der ganz besonders auf seine
tiere achtet das ist ein feld bei den
teuren flaschen
ja aber da hat ist und viele viele
menschen die sich auch ist natürlich
auch leisten können das ist natürlich
dass alle punkte
das muss einfach versuchen auch diese
wertschätzung dem tier gegenüber und
dürfen auch nicht bringen
aber wie gesagt geht er kann sich es
nicht leisten und das schlimmste ist
überhaupt wenn ein staat anfängen
unabhängig vom vom fleisch jetzt preis
ihr vorzug geben wir wie geht es dann
weiter
was wird als nächstes dann vom staat
vorgegeben ich würde ihnen sowieso und
tatsächlich staatsgläubig geworden also
denke ich denke auch also verbote ist
immer finde ich das letzte mittel es
geht wirklich darum verdient und
überzeugung und sie haben auch aufklären
wie es mal runterbrechen auch selber
persönlichen beispiel ich habe früher
viel unbedenklicher fleisch in mich
hinein gegessen sage ich jetzt mal ob
das jetzt würstchen waren oder malen
dollar um die ecke
das findet in der form nicht mehr statt
bei mir persönlich ist ein anderes
bewusstsein entstanden auch durch die
aufklärung und die auseinandersetzung
damit und das ist glaube ich etwas wo
wir in zukunft sogar noch über vitro
sprechen werden
nämlich fleisch was sozusagen
produzieren hört was dann vielleicht
auch diesen kulturkampf zwischen veganer
vegetarier und fleischesser aufheben
würde also ich ende das wir uns dann
einig hört sich jetzt wahrscheinlich
ganz schlimm an unvorstellbar aber das
thema wird kommen da bin ich voll
überzeugt ich habe jedes soll doch
selbst natürlich soll jeder selber
entscheiden aber dann soll er auch
wissen wie dieses gleich zustande kommt
genau aber ich glaube der ist ein
umdenken ist ja schon da ja gesellschaft
grundidee ist natürlich toll aber sagen
am marschieren jetzt einfach so
umzusetzen und vor allem auch dem
endverbraucher muss einfach daran denken
das ist wirklich nicht immer im budget
passend ist dass ich überlegen kann
nämlich dass aus der frischetheke oder
nehme ich das jetzt direkt vom metzger
oder nämlich das abgepackte das geht
immer natürlich verschiedene bedürfnisse
und budgets die man hat
[Musik]